[Musique]
louis-marie 7 bonjour bonjour monsieur
livory vous avez 57 ans est candidat du
causse vous allez conduire la liste unie
pour ducos c'est bien cela s'est mieux
cela c'est votre troisième participation
aux élections municipales qu'est ce qui
vous motive encore alors d'abord je vais
saluer tous et et toutes celles qui nous
écoutent et qui nous regardent et
particulièrement les dicos 16 et du coup
c'est ce qui m'anime c'est que je suis
d'abord et de conseil je vis à du crunch
j'aime ducos et je n'ai jamais délaissé
le terrain je suis depuis 18 ans bobby
2001 conseiller municipal et début 2014
et du communautaire et je n'ai donc
jamais lâché le terrain et autour de moi
il ya une équipe une équipe qui est
composée de femmes et d'hommes de trans
générationnel et et générationnelle même
on dirait et nous avons des projets pour
ducos changement ce ne seront prises ont
pas est ce que c'est la fenêtre du tir
et c est ce que c'est la fenêtre de tir
la dernière fenêtre de tir
jamais je ne maîtrise pas le temps mais
je pense que effectivement quand on
regarde bien jeu à chacune des élections
où j'ai participé en 2008 j'étais
candidat et en 2014
je suis sorti toujours 2e à première
avec 2000 voit donc un matelas de 2000
voix et je crois que avec le travail
qu'on a opéré entre 2014 et aujourd'hui
avec l'assentiment de la population je
crois que c'est eux mêmes qui nous
disent je comprends moment est arrivé et
je crois que la population nous fait
plus confiance parce que ils nous disent
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai mûri en expérience
ces 18 années nos positions dans
l'équipe municipale ont permis d'avoir
cette expérience
en plus d'avoir une expérience
communautaire alors vous êtes membre du
ppm parti progressiste martiniquais mais
vous n'avez pas demandé l'investiture ça
fait but cela se fait beaucoup
maintenant dans les différents partis
pourquoi vous n'avez pas demandé
l'investiture chip
j'ai effectivement comme on dit je n'ai
pas demandé de la vessie
par contre j'ai un soutien massif
soutien fort du brasier boris de
martinique c'est parce que j'ai toujours
tenu une parole frais très franche avec
mes amis du coup je suis président du
grand rassemblement du procès une
association politique sur detox et on a
toujours oeuvré dans le sens pour que
nous il y as autour de nous des gens qui
sont dans différentes tendances
politiques et c'est pour cela que nous
avons choisi de rester dans cette mostra
et que tous nous travaillons sur du
cross même si chacun connaît ma position
politique alors un sujet sera au centre
de la campagne c'est bien sur les
finances de la ville
la ville de du conseil est épinglée par
la crc la somme régionale des comptes
votre vision des choses alors vous savez
je dirais même pour nous pour moi tout
cas c'est presque derrière moi le
rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes puisque c'est une situation j'ai
dénoncé depuis beaucoup d'années depuis
2004 que je disais que ça allait
jeannette ça n'allait pas bien
et donc aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut
bâtir un projet à partir de la situation
financière et de l'api situation
administrative de la ville qu'on connaît
s'éterniser sur le sur la situation
financière crois que tout le monde
connaît la situation il faut aujourd'hui
nous passions à la vitesse supérieure de
dire qu'est ce que nous pouvons faire et
c'est le but de matt rady d'atur dans
cette élection
on va passer dans deux secondes au trait
aux programmes
mais il faut aussi rassurer les agents a
tout à fait le des piliers de notre
action c'est de rassurer et je le dis
très clairement il n'y aura pas de
licenciements nous ne serons tous tout
ce qui est de notre possible pour éviter
toute sorte de licenciement et nous
allons donc attaquer immédiatement je
dirais chantiers de négociation de
discussion des choses avec le personnel
pour qu'ensemble nous puissions relever
ce défi mais là c'est assez préconise
aussi une augmentation des impôts alors
la chambre régionale effectivement
préconise diminution du personnel et
augmentations d'impôts ne sommes ni pour
l'un ni pour l'autre c'est pour cela que
il y a procès de
des changes il ya d'autres moyens de
faire des économies sur le train de vie
de la ville sur les dépenses en tout cas
de l'électricité dos tout ce qui
s'ensuit
ce sont des pavés on peut travailler
fortement dessus il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation de la pression fiscale ne
voulons pas ou plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que la ville de düren ne connaît
pas de problème de recettes donc nous
n'avons pas ces problématiques ces
problèmes de gestion
donc nous irons devant le préfet pour
lui présenter des mesures que nous
comptons mettre en place dans les trois
quatre années de la maladie
l'ex fort de votre campagne se croit il
est très peu de temps
l'action de le capal c'est de faire en
sorte que ville du crotoy une ville
d'excellence excellence en matière de
qualité de vie
excellence en matière de qualité de
projet excellence en matière d'enjeux
culturel excellence en matière de
dangereux touristique excellence en
matière d'enjeux sportif est aussi un
enjeu d'excellence de manière de manière
environnementale et numérique parce que
je veux que du cosfa tourner vers
l'avenir et ça c'est possible du cos
parce que nous aurons un management
adapté
louis morissette je vous reviens c'est
moi qui vous remercie monsieur livre hui